hey not so bad all right we're back
making spicy lobster pasta with the one
the only the infamous and fantastic
human Mario
Carbone okay Mario how is the pasta
looking now angel hair capalini not too
long in the cook right quick cook uh
stays hot for a really long time all
right we coat that we stir it in back on
the fire and the last bit of the cooking
will happen here where you just kind of
that looks good bring it all together
let it let it let it let it come
together into one kind of happy oh it
coalesces it coal leses
yum okay so how do we finish that off
how does Mario Carbone do it I'm about
to show you I want to see it we're going
to Twirl in plate together oh my God
okay I'll
twirl all right Carbone shirt okay so
you get kind of like a good mm good size
pin it run it up so it's not too and
then you're going to try to hit the
center which you did
perfectly
yeah pinch and twirl please pinch and
twirl all
right now I went a little smaller oh see
I've already screwed it up but that's me
no we we'll clean that up don't worry
I'm oh we've got a pouette I'm
come
on all right now we get to do the
funnest part which is mangra MRA tasty
tasty let's do
it oh my gosh I can't believe I'm eating
Mario's
pasta h h h who
that
hot
yeah stays hot stays hot for I know I
agree really hot I totally
agree yeah oh my God so
[Laughter]
[Applause]
bad that's
it that's so
good um okay
we have some really fun trivia cuz we
asked audience member Sarah um some
pasta trivia and if she gets it right um
she is going to get a huge prize um okay
the question was according to the
international pasta organization how
many different pasta shapes are there a
200 B 600 c
1,000
Sarah I want to say b600
oh my God it's me it's me
it's oh my
God that was so stressful that was so
stressful oh my
gosh I'm so relieved do you know why I'm
so relieved Sarah me too you're going to
Italy that's
right you and and a guest are getting
a you and a guest are getting a five
nights day at the luxury up five star on
anaro palaza naad Rome hotel which
includes two meals a day and round trip
airfare everything is taken care
[Applause]
of and everyone in the audience is going
home with a jar of Mario's Famous spicy
do
[Applause]
um Sarah can you tell us one thing about
yourself um actually I can tell you a
lot of things about myself are you
getting emotional I live for
emotion this is amazing I just got laid
off and so this is like the best gift
ever no
really was it a job that you loved or
made you happy um it paid the bills so
that was great I was there for eight
years um so I really wasn't expecting it
so this is exciting but it's a great
thing because I get to change the course
of my career which I've wanted to do for
years so is kind of the universe pushing
me in that
direction and this is this oh my God
this is the best prize right here
confident you screw it here I got to
come over
here thank you so much sorry it's so
hard to climb over with the heels you
got to help me okay move over move over
sit down okay so I'm so excited that
upon you know what must be a challenging
time that something great could happen
and you could go to Italy and like Take
On The World and get a fresh start and
come back with a newfound you know Gusto
and just like take it on and get it
done thank you so
[Applause]
much
mja mja all right thank you thank you
thank you
Mario well look at that I just I feel
like look at all thank God she got that
right I right exactly it's a sign for
good things to
[Applause]
come thank you Sarah thank you Mario
we'll be right
back